c'est une tradition chrétienne qui perd
progressivement du terrain à l'occasion
du dimanche des rameaux et de la semaine
sainte qui se termine à pâques les
fidèles vont fleurir les tombes de leurs
défunts fini le temps des rameaux ou du
guit béni est désormais un bouquet de
fleurs peut suffire chez les
horticulteurs force est de constater que
ce sont majoritairement les anciens qui
font perdurer cette coutume confirmation
avec romain delville ce n'est peut-être
pas le même engouement la même affluence
que la semaine qui précède la toussaint
chez cet horticulteur de saint martin
des bois mais giroflées cinéraire fleurs
d'embellissement des tombes part comme
des petits pains en cette veille de
week-end des rameaux c'est ce que je
disais en général les gens viennent plus
pour la toussaint fleury sli tombe que
pour les rameaux nous on a toujours fait
la passe était familière amener des
fleurs aux rameaux et puis à la
toussaint c'est je vous ai fait normal
ces deux marques de respect envers
moment il n'y a pas que la période des
rameaux et à la période aussi toute
l'année
toute l'année on peut mettre une pièce
malgré un fléchissement des ventes il y
a quelques années la tradition des
rameaux se maintient en touraine et
c'est presque une exception local chez
certains collègues les rameaux n'existe
pas c'est vraiment ancrée chez nous de
génération en génération et nos grands
parents surtout fleurissaient beaucoup
dé tous or amour
la nouvelle génération un petit peu
moins et c'est quelque chose qu'on
essaie de faire perdurer malgré que nous
sachons que depuis quelques années les
ventes pour les cimetières oramo diminue
quoi car vallée les jeunes générations
ne frise pas autant que nous que nos
ancêtres en tout 5000 composition de
giroflées et 5000 composition de
cinéraire ont été préparées de longue
date par franck niveau et son équipe
quelques-unes resteront la semaine
prochaine pour les retardataires